[Music]
welcome to another episode of LED live
everyone we're grateful that you could
join us on another Friday at noon which
is typically when we air but not always
today we're going to talk about the
history of the Sabbath which has been
you know something we have touched on
here and there in our show and we want
to talk about how this has been for a
very long time and and what that
relevance has for us today like how did
these things come about how did people
observe it when you know what people
groups and so to help guide us through
that we have James who's very familiar
with this topic and has presented on it
many times before James you also have a
YouTube channel right where you're
discussing lots of things from history
so if you're a student of history and
you like to learn about interesting
things from history where do they go
yeah so it's going to be biblical hope
which is just one word uh there's no
space between them but yeah biblical
hope biblical Hope on YouTube check it
out and so where are we going to start
today what time period are we going to
start obviously we know that the Sabbath
was something instituted in the Garden
of Eden yeah I don't know if we're
launching from there or are we going to
launch later on in history more modern
times yeah so I think most people are
probably familiar with the Sabbath as it
was before the time of Christ maybe most
people are familiar that you know it
began at creation we see that in Genesis
2 where the Lord blesses the Sabbath day
and even in the context of the
Commandment itself in Exodus 20 we see
where the Commandment itself references
God blessing the Sabbath at creation but
the part where it gets really contested
is around the time of Christ uh you know
you see a lot of people talking about
well you know it shifted to Sunday
because that's when Christ resurrected
and their perception is that the early
Church did so in unity and that there
was this entire transformation to Sunday
and that Sabbath keeping didn't really
come back on the the pages of History
until maybe 18 1900 years later and you
know that's just really not reflected in
the the the documents that we have and
so we're going to take a look at those
today and maybe some scripture text as
well to see some Illusions to what
happened and um
yeah let's let's let's Dive Right In so
I'm sure you guys are probably familiar
with some of these scripture texts
Matthew
24:20 Christ said in that chapter about
pray that your flight be not in Winter
neither on the Sabbath day and do you
guys know what he was referencing at
that time what is Matthew 24 all
about the end of time right or at least
that's that's what the disciples were
inquiring about when Jesus launched into
this this whole speech they think the
world is falling apart and ending when
he's talking about these things so my
question is why would Christ reference
the Sabbath day in an event that was yet
future and Beyond the cross if the
Sabbath day was no longer uh to be
observed or no longer an institution so
it had to have continued past the time
of the Cross yeah the historical reality
of this is he's talking about the fall
of Jerusalem which is coming which
happens in 70 AD so yeah why is Jesus
asking them pray that your FL it's not
on the Sabbath in 70 AD it hasn't
occurred yet he's assuming they're still
going to be doing that right which is a
fascinating point right and you know we
see that that was the the custom of
Christ uh in Luke 4:16 as his custom was
he went into the synagogue on the
Sabbath day and stood up to read now if
we're Christians and we want to follow
the example of Christ well here's an
example that Christ set that we want to
follow and you know Paul did so himself
in Acts
17:2 Paul went to the synagogue and on
three sabbaths he reasoned them from the
scriptures now you know a lot of people
are going to say well Paul went in there
just because he wanted to prize to the
Jews right but let's take a look at acts
13:42 did Paul go there to preach
exclusively to the Jews no no we see you
know we see the Gentiles besought that
these words might be preached to them
the next Sabbath
and so it was a day for both Jews and
Gentiles in fact if you go back to
ancient Israel what came which came out
of Egypt the law applied to the mixed
multitude was the mixed multitude just
Jews or was it Jews and Gentiles Jews
and Gentiles exactly so it was something
that was made for mankind and that's
what Christ said in Mark the other thing
I find fascinating it's a perfect
opportunity to
breach something different you know
Jesus is like let me clarify that's G to
be on Sunday or Paul like you know what
you guys don't have to come here on to
the synagogue on Sabbath I'll just meet
with you tomorrow yeah doesn't say that
doesn't suggest that doesn't insinuate
that yeah you know one of the classic
texts that's used to that people try and
prove it with his acts 20:7 where they
gather together and break bread but the
problem is is acts 2:46 shows that they
broke bread daily so if you're doing
this every day what does that prove
about Sunday if it's something you're
doing every day of the week including
the seventh day I might no more no more
sacred than any other day exactly you
know in Acts 1613 we read on the Sabbath
day we went out of the city to the
Riverside where prayer was customarily
made and we sat down and spoke to the
women who met there so this isn't just
the synagogue that he's going to he's
going to where prayer is customarily
made uh he's he's wherever you know he's
going and meeting on the Sabbath day to
speak to these people now we said a
moment ago about Jews and and Gentiles
well let's take a look at acts
18:1 is Paul arguing exclusively to Jews
on the Sabbath day in Acts
18:1 while we read down in verse 4 he
reasoned in the synagogue every Sabbath
and persuaded both Jews and Greeks
exactly so this isn't this isn't just
you know a prz to Jews he is speaking to
mankind on the Sabbath day and you know
Paul himself the same person who wrote
you know Colossians 2:16 and 17 which
are which people are going to try and
argue for you know the Sabbath no longer
being kept which actually references the
the ceremonial sabbaths spoke about this
sabbath the moral Sabbath he said there
remains a Sabbath rest for the people of
God for the one who's entered his rest
has himself rested from his works as God
did from his therefore let us be
diligent to enter that rest so that no
one will fall through though following
the same example of Disobedience now
guys let me ask you a question is
resting on Sunday resting as God rested
no no no because he's referencing back
to Genesis that's what he's talking
about and he's saying God rested from
his work so it's talking about the
seventh day after creation that's how
God rested and so this is an interesting
passage I wrote a paper on this and um
this is the only time where the word
sabbatismos appears in Greek it's the
only time
and I traced this passage in Hebrews 3
and 4 all the way back to uh Exodus
Through the Bible and and it's very
clear that it's it's talking about the
the seventh day Sabbath and so um and
Paul puts it in a way that shows that
it's it's about righteousness by faith
yeah you know that it's just it's a
beautiful beautiful picture some Bible
translations translate that Sabbath rest
is just rest and I got to wonder if
those translators were were translating
sabbatismos as just rest to avoid the
condemnation of the verse for their own
actions when you look at the
commentaries of all these people who are
biblical Scholars they they really try
to push the envelope they'll come like
right up to trying to deny it but they
they know that they can't because if
you're going to be true to the text and
you know and see what it's saying and
realize this is a reference to Genesis
and then there's other clues that it
would not be
intellectually um honest or yeah it
would not be intellectually honest to
dismiss it James you brought up
Colossians and so for our audience can
you uh make a distinction between the
ceremonial Sabbath and the moral Sabbath
yeah so Colossians 2:16 uh starting at
verse 14 it talks about the law that
stood as a witness against us and if you
go back to Deuteronomy
31:26 you can see the law that stood
against us was this one that that sat on
the side of the Ark and so it was not
the one within but it was the one that
sat beside the ark you know Paul
declares that the law is Holy just and
good and what we find here is a
distinction about the ordinances and if
you go back to Ephesians 2:15 we see
that the the law contained in ordinances
was abolished and that word abolished is
the same one where Christ speaks
regarding the moral law back in in
Matthew where think not that I have come
to abolish the law but to fulfill so the
moral law remains but the law contained
in ordinances in Ephesians 2:15 was
abolished and so when we took take a
look at the context of those ordinances
in Colossians 2:16 and 17 it's talking
about meat and drink and it's talking
about Sabbath days now the the decalogue
doesn't mention anything about food or
drink right but if you go back to
Leviticus 23 you can see that there is a
reference to meat and drink and Festival
Sabbath in the context of the ceremonial
law which was all instituted to point
forward to the sacrifice of Christ on
the cross and so when he came and
fulfilled all of that there's no need
for that but the moral law remains and
as established as Paul taught in Hebrews
4 so excellent thank you yeah um now you
know we're not alone in in this uh
position on the early church Theodore
Zayn was a German Protestant Theologian
and nominated for a Nobel Prize in
literature three times but his
commentary on the early church was that
the Sabbath was a strong tie which
United them with the life of the whole
people and in keeping the Sabbath holy
they followed not only the example but
also the command of
Jesus so it's interesting here how um we
see the recognition here of following
the command of
Christ now guys you know
the interesting part is how the early
church uh communicated the truth of the
Gospel to the world
Clement spoke about Paul after preaching
both in the East and the West he gained
the illustrious reputation due to his
faith of having taught righteousness to
the whole world and come to the extreme
limit of the West and suffering
martyrdom under the prefects now I've
included this Latin work here and folks
the reason why is because for me I like
to go and Trace the original language
and Latin documents to kind kind of see
where uh these documents have spoken
about this topic back during the time of
the Reformation earlier so it allows the
audience to say you can go punch in
these words on Google Books and go see
you know how this has been a topic of
debate and discussion for many years so
it makes it easier to just find that
quote really really quick on Google
books but you know Romans 15 Paul talked
about going and visiting Spain and I'll
tell you why that's interesting to me if
we go to our map here of
Western Europe you can see how Paul if
he's in Rome and he goes ultimately to
Spain there's a little city there near
Barcelona where uh the city is called
sabadell and it is thought to have been
named after the Dell of the Sabbath
Keepers now if you look at where he
might have traveled up through the the
Alps maybe places like Genoa or maybe
places like uh uh you know certain
aspects of the Swiss
Alps and he's teaching the gospel of
Christ to these people here you can see
how the Sabbath might have been
communicated to them and I think this is
where we see the Sabbath reflected in in
documents and in individuals and people
groups in those areas churches that
arose up and carried the torch in the
wilderness for many many years up to the
time of the Reformation but it it it
paints a picture of how that might have
been communicated so are you saying the
name of that place came after Paul's
pilgrimage okay or Paul's Journey yeah
um you know there's another aspect of
scripture though that I want to cover
here and that would be the day of the
Lord or the Lord's day okay okay now you
guys are probably familiar with second
Peter 3:10 what is the context of second
Peter 3:10 what what are we talking
about here Second Coming yeah exactly so
what's going to happen at the second
coming it'll be sudden yeah very visible
audible lots of loud noises and flashes
of lightning and brightness and can't
miss it fire yeah yeah exactly you know
one of the things that I see here though
is that the day of the Lord that's
talked about here in the Greek we have
Kyo and we have Hamera Hamera being the
word for day and you guys can look this
up on Bible Hub and double check but you
know there's You'll Always Find that
with the day of the Lord where there's
Kyo and there's Hamera if you go back to
the Greek manuscripts so here's a
closeup of this you guys can take a look
for yourselves Kyo chera and you can see
the same thing in first Thessalonians 52
for you know for yourselves know
perfectly that the day of the Lord shall
come as a thief by night right so once
again Kyo H H being the Greek word for
day now it gets a little bit complicated
because in Revelation 1:10 we have
another word very similar kir Hamera or
kir Hamera um once again the the Lord's
day and do you guys know what what was
the context of of John's Vision in
Revelation 1:0 do you remember that uh
well it says just here he says I'm I was
in the spirit on the Lord's day he's
about to receive a vision he's on Patos
he's
isolated and God is about to reveal this
entire vision from The Book of
Revelation to himh so yeah people have
taken this to more or less assume that
it meant that it's talking about
Sunday without developing a context here
John doesn't say what day it is like
specifically he doesn't say it was
Saturday or it was Sunday he just says
on the Lord's day and when you put that
together with a lot of other evidences
there's a couple of ideas that rise to
the top um one is he's talking about the
great and terrible day of the Lord um
like we have in second Peter so it's a
reference to that another one is that
it's talking about the Sabbath because
we don't have any evidence that suggests
that John stopped keeping the Sabbath so
the Lord's day to him would be the
Sabbath just like you have Jesus saying
uh and the son of man is also Lord of
the Sabbath so those are two ideas that
that arise in biblical scholarship yeah
and even verse seven you know he hears
trumpets behind him and you think about
the Trump of God you know waking the
dead like there there's there's evidence
here this talking once again in the same
context as the previous Apostles about
the day of the Lord but the problem is
is that this verse is sometimes used to
support Sunday right when the context
doesn't support that however once again
there is that word homera now one of the
earliest works that is referenced to
talk about the change from Saturday to
Sunday is the diday and you can read
Lightfoot who was a English Theologian
and preacher at St Paul's Cath cedral
Bishop of Durham who translated this but
every Lord's Day gather yourselves
together and break bread now this is
plate 9 folio Ada of the Codex H which
is the earliest version of the deday
that we know of and the problem is is
Hamera in this particular section right
here doesn't exist and so there have
been a lot of Scholars that have say
wait a second hold on you're Translating
that but every Lord's Day gather
yourselves together and the text doesn't
support that without the word day for
Hamera you could just as easily
translate it according to the Lord's
dedic or doctrine okay uh according to
the Lord's Doctrine gather yourselves
together and break bread and give
Thanksgiving so this this work does not
actually support Sunday what people
think however there are works like the
oxy ranus Papi except he make the
Sabbath a real Sabbath ye shall not see
the father these were sayings that
supposedly Jesus said that these people
in Egypt had recorded and you you can
see how you know there's evidence there
that maybe they they did recognize and
keep the Sabbath uh can we back up here
the the slide previous so the person who
was doing this translation that's what's
in our text today yeah yeah you will
read but every Lord's Day gather
yourselves together and break bread but
the problem is is that the day that they
put in there the word Hamera there is no
h right so that's pretty significant so
what do we do with that was that a
malicious thing or was he translating
the text based off of his own bias he
truly thought that that was the case the
problem is is that the word kir uh has
been so long associated with Sunday by
tradition that the meaning of the word
has been has been changed and so they
believe it means Sunday when if you go
back to scripture and the way that the
Greek is actually used it's always been
linked with Hamera you have a it gets to
be really kind of a complicated problem
because you have
multiple um documents that have been
left behind for translation multiple
texts right then Scholars will also look
at not just those but they will look at
the writings of people of the day and
particularly like people who are Church
fathers or Elders or Bishops or whatever
and they'll look and see how it's used
in their documents as well to see like
you know the ones that we have does this
all fit together does it all you know
support right um what it is so yeah like
he's saying people also it's I mean
we're human beings we we do have biases
yeah and so you can have people that are
like well you know I'm reading this and
I'm translating this and and I believe
this is what they meant but where's the
place for the Holy Spirit there cuz
that's very impactful for that kind
translation I mean doctrines are built
off of it he's got a really good point
though because as far far back
as I don't know Council of N and all
these other things you do have the
traditions of the forefathers and what
they said being used as validation and
justification for setting aside the
Lord's day as Sunday as far back as we
can remember so it's so hard what the
problem is is that they only quote their
side of the church I know exactly that's
the thing but again they look at proof
way back when to see that they are um
translating it I guess in the right way
make sure that they have that right
slant okay so for the readers today is
it for us to do our due diligence and
actually look at those original texts I
mean how how how deep does this go in in
terms of other scripture well verses
yeah let's let's take a look at some of
those uh some of those texts here so Pho
of Alexandria from about 20 BC to 50a
said that the seventh day is the
completion of creation for it is the
festival not of a single city or country
but of the Universe I mean that's not
just Jews that's everybody and you know
one of the earliest uh individuals in
history polycarp do you guys remember
who his teacher was I thought it was
John exactly the same one who wrote
Revelation 11:0 on the preparation at
the hour of dinner there came out
pursuers and Horsemen and polycarp was
killed on the day of the great Sabbath
at the 8th hour now the preparation
would have been Friday and on the
Sabbath he would have been killed at the
8th hour now when one of the things that
I find interesting is here we have
Christ as his custom was he goes in the
synagogue on the Sabbath day and stood
up to read Paul as his custom was three
Sabbath reason them from the scriptures
and then V polycarp on the following
Sabbath he said hear my exhortation
beloved children of God there's there's
a consistent custom there of following
the apostles before him yeah which is
one of the evidences why we can point to
Revelation and say John probably wasn't
talking about Sunday if those who
studied Direct under him are also
teaching and preaching and pointing to
the Sabbath yes what what do we read in
Mark 227 to 28 you know Jesus Christ is
Lord of the Sabbath day yeah they also
martyred pretty much everyone who stood
for this why would it be such a threat
to them you know in their forefather's
thoughts there's um yeah this this is
kind of a big topic but when you look at
like why did these changes happen he
kind alluded to like not all the
churches are on the same page you have
Alexandria is very different than um uh
what's the other one Antioch yeah and
you know the Romans contrary to what
people probably believe the Romans were
actually pretty religiously
tolerant they they didn't have a lot of
beef with people of other religions what
they had a problem with was Insurrection
they wanted to be the only politic iCal
power on the Block so if you were like
rising up in arms against them then they
got a problem with you so the early
Christians what they started to run into
was the Jews were very um very much
insurrectionist they hated Rome didn't
want anything to do with Rome wanted
Rome out and they would rise up in arms
resistance to them so when Christians
start and they keep the Sabbath and they
eat a certain way and they worship a
certain way and they have all these
similarities with Christ or with Jews
the Romans are looking at them going are
you Jews M and they get real suspicious
of
them and so what that does is it puts
pressure on the Christians over time to
distance themselves from Jews and there
were a couple of different ways that
they did that some of the churches
started worshiping on Sunday to say no
no no no we're not Jews we don't we're
not I mean yeah we keep the okay well
we'll worship on Sunday so that you know
that we're different or we'll start
eating unclean Meats so that you know
that we're different you know all kinds
of different things not all of them did
that but some of them did yes to draw
that distinction yeah and this is one of
the earliest examples we have of of some
of the reasons why the change occurred
so the Epistle of Barnabas said that we
keep the Eighth Day Sunday with
joyfulness the day also on which Jesus
rose again from the dead now ebus of
cesaria recogniz that this was a spirous
fictitious book it was you know
influenced uh in such a way that wasn't
you know it wasn't an accurate work and
but one of the origins for that Eighth
Day idea was from gnosticism irenaeus of
Leon and guys you got to remember where
is Leon again France yeah exactly it's
France or kind of around that area that
Paul would have you know walked through
on his way to Spain we see where the
agnostics affirm that man was formed on
the eth day but sometimes they will have
him to have been on the sixth day and
sometimes on the eth uh it was a it was
a means of separating the Flesh and from
you know because they believed that the
flesh was evil and the spirit you know
was good so you had the fleshly part on
the eth and well his Earthly part was
formed on the sixth day and his fleshly
part on the eth so these two things were
distinguished by them which just real
quick sounds a little bit more like like
you're saying gnosticism or even
metaphysics in the occult world because
they're always trying to separate the
physical from the spiritual MH and
somehow keep them very separate and yeah
and you know uh victorinus of Pau in the
third Century talked about the
nicians who believed that they would
receive peace on the eth day so whoever
should have committed fornication might
receive peace on the eighth day and so
it just it just shows how you know the
nicians were condemned by John right
that was one of the things that that
that God had a problem with in the seven
churches they were the ones who did this
piece on the Eighth Day business of
Sunday and they also I believe in the
Bible there's a verse about the nians
specifically being called out by Jesus
or God has his thoughts on them and how
he despises them exactly it's it's
questioned on whether or not he was
actually one of the original Seven
deacons and went a stray oh and because
I think uh Nicholas was one of the seven
deacons and so this you know would have
made him a very prominent figure so the
fact that he you know took a left turn
in in history and had was able to lead
people away it would make sense you know
from some
perspective um but yeah he was now
briefly who are the seven deacons or
where does that come well you're talking
about um after the early Christians the
the leaders were like we can't handle
all this stuff we can't be waiting on
tables and and this kind of thing in the
early church so they're like okay we
need to appoint seven Deacons
uh the you know the early
Apostles and so people like stepen ah he
was one of the seven deacons the first
Christian martyr so okay I don't have
them all memorized off the top of my
head but theopus Bishop of Antioch said
on the sixth day God finished his Works
which he made and rested on the seventh
day and he recognized that this word
Sabbath is translated into Greek the
seventh a name that is adopted by every
nation although they know not the reason
of this appalation and you can think
about this today in the languages like
sabado you know or Sabato or saboda or
all the different languages that you can
think of that the Sabbath is on the
seventh day uh pseudo aanus there's been
some discussion about whether or not
this was athanasius or archelus or
somebody else but he said that we
assemble on Saturday not that we are
infected with Judaism but only to
worship Christ the lord of the Sabbath
amen and you know this was recognized
later on in like the time of the
Reformation when with you know primitive
Christianity where they assembled on
Saturdays not that they were infected
with Judaism but just to worship Christ
the lord of the Sabbath now you know a
lot of people will interpret Hebrews 4:9
to say well okay Jesus is my Sabbath and
what they're conflating is the person
with the time you know and so origin
answers that question where on Hebrews
4:9 he says there remaineth therefore a
sabbatismos that word you mentioned
earlier m that is a keeping of the
Sabbath to the people of God so there's
no question they didn't they didn't
misinterpret this to say oh well Jesus
is my Sabbath so therefore I don't have
to keep a day at all anymore which is
kind of ludicrous if you think about it
because they're busy keeping Sunday so
why would you keep any day then yeah it
doesn't make sense yeah now
tulan initially scorned the seventh day
Sabbath but after becoming more
acquainted with the more conservative
Christian groups from Asia Minor you
think about the East they kept it way
farther than the west and he said later
on in his Works thus Christ did not at
all resend the Sabbath he kept the law
thereof but more so he consecrated it an
additional sanctity by his own
beneficient action where he gave this
day Divine safeguards a course which his
adversary would have pursued for some
other days well doesn't that sound
familiar that sounds like Sunday right
uh to avoid honoring the Creator's
Sabbath so there you have it folks there
is a recognition that uh um there was
some recognition of the Sabbath there in
the early church and Socrates
scholasticus said almost all churches
throughout the world celebrate the
sacred Mysteries of the Sabbath of every
week yet the Christians of Alexandria
and at Rome on account of some ancient
tradition have ceased to do this now
what was Alexandria infected with the
ult yeah yeah that was the seat of Satan
for a long time exactly Antioch is the
place where they were first called
Christians according to the book of Acts
so is a a stronghold of of
Christianity yeah afrat Syrian said that
let us observe the sabbath of God in a
manner which pleases his will let us
enter into the Sabbath of rest in which
the Heaven and Earth take Sabbath rest
all creatures will dwell in peace and
take rest so you know he knew that the
Sabbath remained and
archelus if you guys remember I don't
know if you remember who archelus
debated against but he debated Manny
Manny was a gnostic who ultimately
formed the manans oh yeah okay so the
manans ultimately influenced people like
Augustine right oh so which is a Church
Father EXA Catholic Church exactly but
you know he came from manism from Manny
MH and this is kind of the other side of
the table with archelus as the assertion
that the Sabbath has been abolished we
deny that he has abolished it plainly
for he was himself also Lord of the
Sabbath and there you can there you can
see where he denied the the uh the
destruction of the Sabbath now Jeremy
Taylor in the 17th century recognized
that the keeping of the Sabbath on the
7even they continued until the time of
the leian
council now uh at least perhaps in the
majority there were still those who kept
it as we'll see but at the time of the
lean Council there was this Canon number
where Christians must not judaize by
resting on the Sabbath but must work on
that day so it wasn't a case of just oh
you know you can't rest out anymore no
you have to actually profane it don't
you love this though if I look at this
they're actually making a distinction
even within this quote of the Sabbath
versus the Lord's Day exactly yeah it's
not one and the same mhm yeah yeah and
you know in the East there was a little
bit of push back on this so Gregory of
Nissa said how can you look upon the
Lord's day if you neglect the Sabbath so
they gradually kind of had this day
creep in but they knew that they were
not supposed to neglect the Sabbath day
Gregory of Nissa knew that but uh even
the East kind of gradually fell away
over time and John of chrisst though
indicated that there were many among who
fast on the same day as the Jews and
keep the Sabbath in the same manner so
there was many many people who kept it
still one of the things that that was
also transpired to create that
distinction between Sabbath and Sunday
is it it came to the point where when
Sunday was going to be emphasized
fasting on Sabbath would be uh
emphasized on on Saturday would be
emphasized and that wasn't typical in
the Jewish culture it was a day of
feasting whereas you might eat two meals
a day you know most of the week on
Sabbath you'd be eating three it was a
day of like you know family and
fellowship and joy and all this but you
know if you want to make something real
Downer MH make it so that people aren't
eating on that day you know they're not
going to look forward to it like oh boy
you know I'm really excited about this
day I'm fasting they just they get
hangry well the interesting thing is is
that even though Sunday began to creep
in they didn't actually rest on the day
so St terome uh and and I I say some
some did not rest on the day some some
did but uh we see Lady Paula who if you
know was kind of uh St Jerome's um you
know student if you will or or some
suggested later on maybe his girlfriend
but um lady Paula who lived at Bethlehem
after service was over on Sunday would
go with her fellow female friends and
would go doing their tasks of making
clothes and garments so they did work on
the Lord's day and this was attested to
by Bishop Francis white in 1635 but you
can go back and read it in Jerome's
works as well so they didn't rest on
Sunday that's kind of a newer uh
institution since Leia and of course um
later on as well but you know St Ambrose
you guys have probably heard of the
expression When in Rome do as the Romans
do right oh yeah I mean a lot of people
don't know that that's actually directly
connected back to that institution of
fasting
on God's Sabbath as a means of degrading
it and elevating the institution of man
of
Sunday now asterus of emia again you can
see this in the East where they
continued to keep holy the Sabbath he
said that joining together in Concourse
of these two days is excellent among
Christians of the Sabbath I mean and the
Lord's day which in a circle returning
time brings about every week for as
mothers and nurses of the church they
both assemble the people and cause the
priests to sit down together and to
teach them so both lead and impel as
well the disciples as their teachers so
then care of souls
now there's obviously a change that
occurred there can you guys think of a
text in the Old Testament that talked
about somebody who would change Divine
Law in Daniel 7 yep Daniel
7:25 um there was also a warning in 2
Thessalonians 2:4 about a power that
would exalt itself above everything that
is called God and in the Latin Vulgate
it's actually e exor supr Omni and here
we have the Pope in the decretals of of
Gregory VI 9th talking about his power
to dispense Above the Law okay sua it's
the same thing in 2 Thessalonians 2:4
about the man of sin or Antichrist the
church began to think that it had power
to change legally Saturday to Sunday and
rabanas marus an Abbot of folda in MZ
Germany said that Pope Sylvester was the
one that decreed the rest from Sabbath
should be transferred to the Lord's
day so we can see I find that
interesting about Sylvester because
Sylvester was the same Pope that some of
the inquisitors later referenced about
the origins of the voois or the Walden
sees and so to me it's interesting that
there's a possible connection there but
in the 4th Century Apostolic
constitutions once again there were
still some groups that kept the Sabbath
day and the Lord's day so they had
Leisure to go to church for instruction
in
piety um the slaves worked 5 days but on
the Sabbath day they had
rest now soan in the fifth century said
that the people of Constantinople and
several other cities assembled together
on the Sabbath as well as on the next
day which custom is never observed at
Rome or at Alexandria another witness
beside Socrates of scholasticus that
Rome and Alexandria were the ones to
have you guys ever heard the accusation
well you just went off and started your
own
church well who really went off and
started their own church here
right here we got the whole rest of the
world doing something different and the
bishop of Rome is going off and starting
his own church you know so um sidonius
said that it it is a fact that it was
formerly the custom of the East to keep
the Sabbath in the same manner as the
Lord's day and to hold sacred assemblies
and he of course he lists all those
people asterus and Gregory Nissa and all
these people so we're not the only ones
that that elude to those early church
fathers Sidonia did so all the way back
in the fifth century and it it actually
still happens today in many churches
whether they're Orthodox or Catholic
they will have a Sabbath
service um and I was kind of surprised
about that I went to England many years
back and we were there in London uh at
uh Westminster Abbey and happened to
arrive on Saturday and they were having
services and I was kind like oh I didn't
know you did that H yeah um you know it
it spread all over it spread up to uh
Scotland and Ireland and you know St
Patrick in the book of arog uh you can
access this online I actually went
through it and found in the original
language there where there's this Angel
victorus who was want to come to him on
every seventh day of the week we and as
one man talks with another so Patrick
enjoyed the Angel's conversation and
that wasn't alone to him there were many
people throughout history who had Angels
who came and talked to them on the
Sabbath day and spent time with them
we've got a lot more examples of that so
uh Columba himself said that of course
when he came to die on the Saturday the
9th of June he said this day is called
the Sabbath that is the day of rest so
he knew which day was the day of rest
and such it will truly be to me because
obviously you know he died on that day
but um you know even our opponents like
the Catholics recognized that alons like
bellesheim for example said that the
Scots in this matter had no doubt kept
up the traditional practice of the
ancient monastic Church of Ireland which
observes Saturday rather than Sunday as
the day of
rest and uh Moffett another scholar back
in 1883 said that that it seems to have
been customary in the Celtic churches of
early times in Ireland as well as
Scotland to keep Saturday The Jewish
Sabbath as a day of rest from
labor now they faced they faced some
push back later on of course in the 11th
century the queen Queen Margaret her
biographer turgot tells how there were
several reforms she tried to Institute
for these early Scots and one of the
things that she comments about them is
that they neglected the reverence of the
Lord's day as in other days so he too
has to insist on laboring that he is not
at all allowed they worked on Sundays
she didn't like that mhm yeah now there
was a lot of persecution that these
early people faced in the church
councils one of the punishments was that
the slave shall receive 100 Stripes if
you worked on Sunday you had to get
beaten is that principle of coercion is
that something that's consistent it's
not exactly religious tolerance
exactly uh Justinian
1 back in his Nolla 144 you got to
remember that Justinian was one of the
individuals who his codex established
civil power for the Roman pontiff back
in 538 and one of the first things that
happened was that there was punishments
instituted for any Samaritans that would
return to their former error and be
detected in observing the Sabbath so
here we have a kind of bookend
for papal power in 538 all the way down
to you know Justinian's law uh not just
Indian but u a Napoleon's codex all the
way down in the 1798 where there's this
this there's this attack on those who
kept the Sabbath and one of the first
ones to do that was Pope Gregory the
first who called individuals who
preached about the Sabbath
Antichrist oh wow now they're literally
trying to follow the example of Christ
and he's calling them Antichrist I mean
isn't that to me that sounds like noism
where you just flip the truth yeah
directly on its head and uh you know
some of the attempts that they went
through to try and influence uh of
course later on in like the 8th Century
you see where Rome tried to literally
Forge documents like the king Dom right
here where they would threaten that if
you don't keep Sunday that there was
going to be heavy Stony hail storms
flying serpents and heathens shall come
to you from me a race of pagans will
carry you into bondage now I got to put
my modern cap here on a moment does this
sound at all like climate
change in other words if you have
somebody at the end of time who tries to
pull the same thing and say well we're
we're going to get sulfurous fire and
thunder and lightning uh if if we don't
rest on this day to me it's it's it's
it's something they've tried for a
thousand years mhm it sounds like Sodom
and gomorra as though they're
justifying sulfur Aspire upon you for
not doing it yeah even in the language
of like the East you can see how the
Sabbath is integrated into their words
like Godly oh yeah you can see how it's
built up of like the number seven and
tent and worshiping for humble and
godliness is like 10th 7th Day and clean
clothes and you know in Exodus
16:29 the Lord has giv you the seventh
day to stay in your tents and don't go
out and pick up food from the ground
that day this was obviously before Mount
Si when the law was given so obviously
the Sabbath existed before Mount Si and
you you know I I think about two how the
apostles taught where the Oracles of of
God were given unto us so this wasn't
something that was exclusive to the Jews
and it was reflected even in the
language in the East my favorite one or
one of my favorite ones is the for boat
you know where it's like eight people
and I'm like where would you get that
like there's no other story right right
we actually have a show that we filmed a
couple of years ago of a Chinese Pastor
we'll put a link in the descrition if
you want a deeper study in this but you
can tell the spirit that's behind this
based off of the progression of how it's
getting more and more intolerant Force
coercion and now even
uh threats making threats from as
they're trying to say from God that if
you don't follow this mhm this is your
your doom your destruction yeah in the
in China you know this was this was even
itched into their Stills this was an 8th
Century one where the seventh day we
offer sacrifices after having purified
our hearts and received Absolution for
our sins this religion so perfect and so
excellent is difficult to name but it
enlightens darkness by its brilliant
precepts and it was in the same Century
that over in again once again you know
France and Northern Italy where you know
you have the Council of froli where we
command all Christians to observe the
Lord's day to be held when speaking of
that Sabbath with the Jews observe the
last day of the week and which also our
peasants observe now hold up folks we
got peasants keeping this in addition to
Jews it sounds to me like maybe they uh
they weren't Jews but they kept the
Sabbath oh Christians keeping the
seventh day Sabbath in the 8th
Century uh in later on of course
yeah insinuation is no educated person
with this is just peasants doing this
you like they're just dumb un educated
masses never mind the fact that of
course later on when rhinaria Sako the
12th century Inquisitor goes and
interviews these peasants he can find
that they can repeat the entire New
Testament word for word and even the
Book of Job on top of that I mean they
were very very well educated they knew
their Bible backwards and forwards wow
and you know we can see of course how
Thomas had some influence on the
Christians in India later on the witness
of of Charles dellan in 1687 but you can
see how when the period of the auto
defay approaches the the individuals
were um charged of having judaized by
attending the solemnization of the
Sabbath and he witnessed that uh and
over in Ethiopia of course there was a
lot of witnesses as well to the
Ethiopians continuing to keep the
Sabbath day and uh this was testified
not only by the church history of
Ethiopia but you can also see even the
Cardinal bellering the Jesuit Cardinal
said that the Ethiopians used these
constitutions those Apostolic
constitutions as truly Apostolic for the
reason of being more mistaken about the
worship of the Sabbath and Sunday they
command to observe the sabbath Ethiopian
Church there's some that over there that
still keep the Sabbath to this day and
so um you know that was something that
that obviously was continuing to be kept
it's almost like they had this you know
anti-semitic yeah undertone to
accomplish all of this well and you you
can see where the idea of you being a
Jew was used as a theological slur for
any Christian who legitimately obeyed
the law of God it was all it was was a
theological slur and in the n9th century
fotus accused once again Witnesses of
these Sabbath Keepers Because You
observe the Sabbath with the Jews and
the Lord stay with us you seem to
imitate with such observance the sect of
nazarenes I guess it shouldn't be
surprising that you know by the time you
get to Martin Luther doesn't really have
this real favorable yeah position or
disposition toward the Jews I mean if
you have centuries of well it's those
Jews that did this did this did this you
know then yeah kind of wind up that way
now you guys know are probably aware
that this that this there occurred in
the 11th century a split between the
East and the West mhm and interestingly
enough when the bishop of Rome wrote to
the Eastern Bishop the patriarch Michael
sarius of
Constantinople um you can see where when
Michael of sarus wrote an open letter
back to the bishop of John he said for
we are commanded also to honor the
Sabbath equally with the Lord's day and
to keep it and not to work on it now he
admitted that they had ceased to do that
practice at least in some sections of
the East but uh
he knew that they were supposed to keep
it and not to work on it but the problem
was is Rome wanted everybody to fast on
it and so ultimately the Bishops came
and denounced the East bitterly plac
their RIT of of excommunication or or
separation right there on the altar in
the left and so there was a contention
over taking it not just where we don't
rest on it anymore but no you've got to
actually fast on the day and profane it
and that's where the East said no we've
had enough and they walked away but
there were those who continued to keep
it and we can see them hiding up in the
Alps and uh uh keeping it of course up
in the the with the vdis the wal denes
one of the individuals that wrote
against them was monetta of Crona and he
accused them of and trying to argue
against uh them using Galatians 4:10 and
Colossians 2:16 which we already talked
about Colossians
2:16 and he accuses them of of being
like the G Gans in chap 4:16 now what do
you guys know about the Galatians in
chapter 4:16 who were the Galatians
first
off not completely sure you mean like
what part of the world are they from
yeah I mean obviously we know that
they're from like Spain ga yeah exactly
Gaul and um they weren't Jews originally
right so if they were returning back if
they were apostatizing when Paul writes
his letter to the Galatians he observe
days months and times if they were
apostasis and going back to paganism
would they have been going back to to
the seventh day Sabbath they never kept
it to begin with right so if they were
apostatizing and going back in
error you know it first off it wouldn't
be of cting keeping the seventh day
Sabbath so that first off is not not a
fair charge by this Inquisitor but also
we can see in Deuteronomy 18:10 and
Isaiah 4713 examples of observers of
times or PR monthly prognosticators or
Pagan days that were kept even back in
ancient Israel St and so they would have
been apostatizing back to that ancient
Babylonian practice which might have
actually included Sunday rest but uh you
know nevertheless it wasn't going back
to Seventh Day Sabbath keeping you find
the same thing when he's writing to the
Ephesian Church you know he tells them
in Ephesians you were once in darkness
but now you're Children of the light
walk as children of the light yeah and
you look at the history of the Ephesian
church and they were entrenched in
paganism and Witchcraft and all this
kind of stuff yeah and uh you know once
again here's another another uh shot of
that text right there but he wasn't the
only one to accuse them of keeping the
seventh day Sabbath the Jesuit
Inquisitor Francis pegy said regarding
the word inabata many used to think it
came from Sabbath that they observed the
Sabbath according to the custom of the
Jews now a lot of people today have
doubted whether or not the W Den SE kept
the seventh day Sabbath citing either
20th century sources the Jesuit Jacob
gretzer who interpreted in sabatti to
reference shoes or or have said well
Walen SE today don't keep the the
Sabbath which that's true they don't uh
but the ancient ones the evidence
suggests that they did in fact even the
Catholic historian Ignat vinger said
that uh not a few celebrate the Sabbath
with the Jews non vum judum
CBR and there's a third Inquisitor the
bones who said not a few but many know
the errors of those who are called pasag
first they teach that we should obey the
Sabbath furthermore so increase their
error and condemn and reject all the
church fathers in the whole Roman Church
there you go though that's the whole
thing is rejecting the church fathers or
tradition and the whole Roman Church
teaching exactly it's a question of
authority right who's whose seal are you
caring if you guys ever noticed like
Sabo the word for Sabo actually has o in
it right at the very end well off is a
Hebrew word if you go back to um for
example Exodus 31:17
where there's this seal that God wants
to put or Ezekiel 20:2 or 20:20 that
seal that Mark of authority is directly
connected to even the word Sabbath
itself MH um now melar Gast also said
about the Walden SE uh not because they
were circumcised but because they kept
the Sabbath The Jewish Sabbath were the
Walden SE called in sabatti doesn't say
it's not a it's not a reference to
Sunday Sabbath there but the Jewish
sabbath
now they didn't uh they were very humble
people they didn't seek to cause offense
to others and so it was interesting how
some of the inquisitors referenced them
uh working on holidays secretly so days
that Rome would consider like holy days
these people were secretly working and
they did so uh as a as a means of not
causing offense uh not giving
unnecessary offense to others who who
believed that but they didn't they
didn't think it was
a sin to work on that day we saw that
back with Lady Paula back in the early
church how she had no problem going back
and and working on the day right um now
the
torpin these were uh some 15th century
pickardy uh Walden
sabbatarians said that well they upheld
the Saturday to be celebrated instead of
Sunday samed and lud de but Paul pu
buzard also recognized that they
celebrated the Sabbath instead of Sunday
and in fact we have a couple of names
here goubert Tulin and Simon beit a
couple of individuals who were arrested
by the Inquisition later on and there
were uh 6 weeks later before a crowd of
10 to 12,000 people there were several
of them who were burned at the stake and
so that's I think one reason why a lot
of people don't see this history anymore
is because there's been entire books
that have been burned there have been
people that have been burned Witnesses
and the evidence has been tried to been
wiped out of the pages of history and so
instead of trusting their Bible they go
read the history that's been fed to them
and miss that there's a whole another
side of the story that hasn't been told
now this history that you're bringing up
and especially this particular um
evidence is it from
like where's it from I guess yeah so
this right here is Paul bizart and it's
actually I got this one from uh I
believe it was either archive.org or or
the French national library one of them
I did get from the French national
library but this particular work was
written in 1912 mhm although we uh we do
find uh some of the evidence uh going
back earlier and for example this one
right here where this was a work by The
Inquisitor heinr Kramer and he wrote
against the valum SE Picard durum herim
so that's the wenes or the picori
picardi es we just saw a reference to
Pier just a moment ago and he said it is
a matter of their blindness over the
change of the Sabbath the mut Sati with
that they do not recognize the authority
of the Roman and Apostolic church now
one of the things I find is that
interesting about that word mut MIM is a
a Latin word to to change and if you go
open your Latin Vulgate and you turn to
Daniel 7:2 the little horn that changes
times and laws it's the same word like
mutation or something yeah I mean
they're just recognizing the little Horn
of Daniel 7:25 and that little horn that
drank the blood of the Saints did
exactly that MH and we can find evidence
of that in September 14th 1492 where
there were hundreds arrested and this
exchange right here is so interesting
how The Inquisitor Gregory uh comes
after Anthony Ferrar and he says you
know well he says You must be Jews since
you say that the law of Moses is still
binding and and the answer waswell we
say that the Ten Commandments are still
binding and he sayses instead of
observing the festivals of the holy
church and honoring the holy day of the
Lord on which he rose from the dead you
were accustomed to meet for worship on
the old Sabbath or Saturday and they
said we did indeed rest and attend a
Divine worship upon the seventh day even
as God
commanded it's like a continuous
redirection like no it's not about
custom or Jewish custom it's what the
Lord commanded us to do exactly and guys
before we close out here for the time
period of to the Reformation we got to
take a look here at some of the ways
which people were manipulated to to keep
Sunday and this is an example of the
anals of Roger toan in 121 where those
who uh who came up to the Lord's day
they could neither buy nor sell anything
so there there was a a Prohibition on
Commerce on the Lord's day where you
couldn't buy or sell anything but more
so you can see this reflected in Pope
Alexander III sin a of Tours the third
lateran Council multiple instructions
against these wild denes where if you
were not obedient to the apostolic sea
you couldn't sell or buy MH does that
sound familiar at all sounds very
familiar yeah I mean it's exactly almost
like a reflection of what you're going
to see at the end of time where you
can't buy or sell MH and there's an
argument over Authority in fact William
the Conqueror in his in his time period
in 1084 you can see bernald of
constantius where he speaks about
William the conquer he made all the land
of English tributory to the Roman
pontiff and did not allow anyone in his
power to buy or sell anything who was
found disobedient to the apostolic sea
there you have it no buy no sell that
happened during Rome's history they're
the ones that came along and said no you
can't buy or sell if you don't obey our
laws what an interesting parallel to the
end of time now you know those who
refuse to learn from the mistakes of
History are due to repeat them right so
doesn't Revelation talk about a beast
that was is not and yet is this is going
to happen at the end of time yes it's
it's fascinating because you look at the
way God does things and you look at the
way Satan does things you know and here
his way is force all the way for force
force force on the Sabbath God also asks
us not to buy and sell mhm
mhm but he he doesn't say well if you
don't I'm going to force you he just
says no you know what you if you want I
want your full attention and to get your
full attention I want to make sure
you're not involved in all these other
Enterprises I don't want to be competing
for our relational
Dynamic so I'm asking that of you would
you please not do those things so that
we can commune together MH you know
instead of saying you will it's will you
but he asked that for us he doesn't do
that without providing because when you
think about it that the Sabbath is a
privilege so to speak not working not
buying or selling that means you've been
provided for to be able to enjoy such a
thing and that is the two things that go
together when it comes to following
God's way yeah I was just listening in
Leviticus this morning and he was
talking about you know when you come
into land um you know make sure that you
don't um Harvest during during this time
and God's like reasoning with him he's
like I know he's kind of like I know
that's going to be hard on you but when
you do that the next time you plant
you're going to harvest like three times
as much I'm going to provide for you
till like the ninth year so don't worry
about the seventh year when you're not
you know when you're not sewing in the
land it's you know it'll do its own
thing but you you'll have enough you
know I will make sure you have enough
that's why these kinds of conversations
I believe are more important or should
be the preliminary before we start
talking about doctrines or telling
people you should just keep Sabbath it's
because how can you ask me to do that
when there's so many things to get done
you know during that time period so
focusing on uh what God provides and and
His blessings and not just that but also
being part of the solution helping
people in their distress uh and and I
mean practical religion as James talks
about helping the widows and the orphans
and all that so that they can see they
can be relieved of their burden as the
Commandment is written in Exodus and
Deuteronomy God says because I have
taken this bondage away from you
therefore go ahead and enjoy the Sabbath
and we need to be part of of helping
people understand that yeah the Sabbath
is is really is it's it's not about you
know us trying to look at this and and
try to Pro prove people that we're right
right it's an invitation
and it's not even our invitation it's
God's
invitation God is saying you know what I
love you I want to spend time with you
this is the time that I've set aside and
it doesn't mean you can't spend time
with God every day but it's the only day
that God said this is the one I blessed
this is the one I Sanctified this is the
day that I I inhabit to be with my
people so come and join me and and when
we do that we experience that that
Bountiful Blessing that you're talking
about and God does provide for us you
can look at the scriptures in in the New
Testament uh which is really the point
of contention in Christianity and you'll
find there's only nine nine verses that
have anything to do with the first day
of the week that's it and that maybe
even including the one in Revelation
that that people but that that's the sum
total of texts five of those texts are
the same event yeah they're just
repeated in the gospels MH so really
you're talking about there's four
scriptures four
events that we're building an entire
foundation on throughout history for
right I mean go look it up for yourself
anybody can go the Bible's public domain
you can look it up and and there's
dozens and dozens of versions you can
check that out but but four do you know
there are nine references no I might
have gotten that backwards I think
there's eight texts that talk about the
first day of the week I think it's eight
five of them in the same event so you
have four texts there are nine nine
references to the Sabbath in the book of
Acts alone nine in Acts alone okay just
in
Acts that's pretty astounding to me when
you look at you know the weight of
evidence like what are we talking about
and we have no specific direction or
command where Jesus or the apostles say
to do
otherwise which it seems pretty clear
you have some some you know derivations
like we talked about like Jesus could be
talking about hey jerusem is about to be
destroyed make sure that on Sunday but
he doesn't say that yeah doesn't say
that and so all these things speak a
volume of evidence and so we want to
invite you all to experience that
blessing and if you haven't ever before
you don't know what to do uh you're
unsure you got questions reach out to us
we're here to answer your questions as
best as we know how and and so that you
can share in the same blessing so I want
to thank you James for coming I know at
the beginning of the show we asked about
you had a YouTube channel where you talk
about this and many other topics and
it's called biblical hope right so check
out biblical hope james' YouTube channel
we'll have a link in the description
below so you can check out and see what
other things he's talking about I love
history I like talking about history so
I find these things very fascinating I
know Aubrey likes history too um I think
KY does yeah she may not voice it as
much as the rest of us but but she likes
it we like history we like you know what
it teaches us because we don't want to
um we don't want to repeat the mistakes
of the past we want to know the truth we
want to know the truth so invite you
guys to check that out this has been
another episode of LED live thank you
for watching make sure you like this
episode subscribe if you've never
subscribed before do that for us it
helps our numbers um you know and if
you've never been here before check out
our other videos we have lots of them we
have playlists to help you if you're
interested in a particular topic you can
also help us out to make more of these
go to L.T
v/g or you can find us on patreon both
of those work uh we actually get a
better rate if you go through our
website so that's just a plug for us
also if you want to help us out we make
t-shirts at lightwear do shop you can
check them out like the one I'm wearing
which is this knockoff of Reese's and it
just says
redeemed and um I think that's the
typical things we talk about so yeah
think I went through the rooll thank you
guys uh hope you can join us next time
and this has been LED live we'll see you
next
time all right I can do
this all
[Music]
right there are conventional ways of
sharing the gospel but some May need a
different way of doing things um never
mind a way that gets the message out
with
confidence wow cool shirt what's a mean
oh thank you you know we're all made
with a unique fingerprint but we're all
God's artwork wow where'd you get
it lightwear wear your Witness
[Music]
and he for you
isra make a killer in the temple of my
God and he shall go out no more I will
ride on him name of my
God in and
power shall your
strength M
Dem shall
run pray alone but by every word that
proceeds from the mouth of God
hey subscribe to little
Studios if you want to learn Spanish a
great way will be watching our videos
for practice
oh
[Music]